there's there's training that's needed
there's sophisticated maintenance
requirements there's a supply chain I
mean it uses a gas turbine engine
basically a jet engine 1500 horsepower
um so there's a lot that goes into
operating these tanks on the field that
said we never ruled tanks out we have
been
um from the beginning of this war now 11
months ago been evolving the
capabilities what we're providing with
Ukraine with the conditions on the
ground and so when you're at to get to
your specific questions what's changed
what's changed Christian are the
conditions on the ground and the kinds
of fighting that the Russians are doing
right now and the kinds of fighting more
importantly that we believe the
ukrainians are going to be need to be
capable of in weeks and months ahead
well into 2023 well into this year what
what this decision does do is show that
how unified we are with our allies and
partners and doing all of this in a
coordinated way so today you saw the
chancellor Schultz announced that
they're going to provide immediately a
company of leopard tanks accompanies
about 14 and there's two companies to a
Ukrainian Battalion and he's going to be
working with allies and partners to get
additional uh companies of Tanks leopard
tanks into Ukraine it's about
coordination it's about the the unity
here and the resolve that that we all
have together to help support Ukraine
that's just what was talked about today
the Brits have agreed to send some of
their Challenger tanks you heard the
president talk about the French and
their contributions to armored vehicles
so there's a there's a lot that's being
applied to this and armored vehicles are
are important you know you uh you don't
go after a crocodile or the corn stalk
and and these in these vehicles these
tanks those those armored vehicles
they're they're going to have they're
going to have an effect